So let's compare update and
invalidate coherence approaches.
We will compare them for different
things that the applications often do.
Here we will say, what the update
protocols are going to do and
here's what an invalidate
protocol is going to do.
If the application has a burst of writes
to one address and if the address is
shared, then each write will send
an update in an update protocol.
This is bad, because each updates
results in competing for the bus,
so it creates bus contention and also it
consumes energy and makes writes slower.
In an invalidate protocol, only the
first write send out an invalidation and
the remaining writes are just going to
be cache hits that don't result in any
bus traffic.
That is good.
Why would an application burst
of writes to one address?
Well, because when we
are computing something,
we may need to update it several times
until we get to the final result.
Another common behavior is
when an application writes to
different words in the same block.
For example,
when we are initializing the block,
we will write every word of that block.
If that block is shared, an update
protocol will send an update for
each word that we write.
That is bad, because it means that one
cache line worth of writes might result
in something like ten updates.
In an invalidation-based protocol,
the first write that we have is going to
invalidate the other copies and
then the remaining accesses to the block
or different words are going to
be just cache hits that
don't result in bus traffic.
So this is again good for
the invalidate, bad for the update.
And the final scenario we will consider
is the producer-consumer scenario,
where the one core keeps writing data
and another core is supposed to read it.
In this case for the update protocol,
the producer will send updates
every time it modifies the data and
the consumer then finds
the data in its cache.
For example, if there is a buffer, the
first pass through the buffer will put
it in the cache and then reading
the buffer, keeps it in the cache.
And here, writes are going to
put new data in the buffer, so
that the consumer just keeps
getting it from its own cache.
This is not great, the producer sends
updates, but it's kind of the best we
can do, because the data really has
to get from one place to the other.
So this is about as good
as this scenario gets.
In an invalidation-based protocol,
however,
the producer will do a write that
invalidates the reader's copy.
So when the reader,
the consumer wants to read,
it's going to be a cache miss and it
has to get the data from the writer and
then a new write will happen and
invalidate the copy and so on.
So this is about as bad as it gets for
this scenario, because not only do we
create bus traffic when we invalidate,
we then have to have a cache miss and
have another bus operation
to get the data.
So as we can see from
this table update and
invalidate based protocols
have different advantages.
So which one do we choose in practice?
Well, it turns out that all modern
processors use the invalidate
type protocol, but
not exactly for these reasons.
As we can see, invalidate-based
protocols have some strengths and
some weaknesses.
Overall, they tend to be slightly
stronger than update on average, but
that's not really the knock out
punch that makes them win handedly.
What really makes them win with no
contest is when a thread moves to
another core.
So a thread was using one core and
then simply the operating system
decides to move it to another core.
So what happens in the update protocol
is that it now will keep updating
the old core's cache.
Note that our working
set was in one cache.
Now, it moved to another one.
But in reality, the other cache still
has blocks that correspond to our data.
So what happens is all the writes
that we make in the near future
are going to be updating the other
course cache until that cache
replaces those blocks by running
another core, for example.
This is pretty horrible,
because a thread movement,
ideally what would happen is we
would just move the data over and
continue working privately
on our private data.
So let's see how this
horrible scenario for
updates works when we
have invalid dates.
In that case,
the first write to each of the blocks
will have to invalidate the old copy.
But after that initial period,
there will be no traffic anymore.
So this is about as good as it
gets without actually taking
the content of the old cache and
copying it explicitly to the new cache.
And again, this is pretty common
operating system behavior.
So we really want it to
perform horribly and
because invalidate-based
protocols are commonly used,
we will now look at invalidation-based
protocols for the rest of this lesson.